that thing like a Marlin for like two
hours yeah you specially have light
tackle TV will be strapped in a chair
for that thing no but look at that
battle hold now well yeah you're gonna
bow it you're gonna battle look at a
[ __ ] oh that's not that's not a muskie
that doesn't look like a muskie to me
that looks like a gar what is it the
caption says ARP i'ma wow or a pieman
yeah that's that gigantic fish that
lives in Bolivia in Ecuador are a Pima
is a fish that lives in the Amazon I
believe somewhere in the rainforest and
they used the locals used to catch him
all the time it was like a big thing for
their food but they're worth so much
money for Americans to go down and fish
for them and now they protect them my
good friend Steve Rinella has a podcast
called meat-eater and he went down and
filmed episode a he also does TV show
and they filmed some episodes their show
in Peru and in Bolivia and those people
the the locals they make a whatever
money that they actually do make they
make a big portion of it some of them do
helping people fish for these things you
know acting as a guide the size of these
things
look at that prehistoric giant animal
and they survive in water when there's a
drought so when the water gets like
super low they're surviving in water
we're like literally like the water's up
to there half their face and there's
waddling around so you could just walk
right up to him we catch them damn I
wouldn't walk up to anything with teeth
like that well they don't have teeth as
big as the Muskies if you go back Jamie
to those pictures see there's a bunch of
them in like water where they're their
upper bodies exposed yeah the water so
shallow and they're so enormous I mean
these are huge huge there's a dinosaur
fish yeah there's you ever seen a gar do
you know what a gar looks like pull up
alligator car alligator gar is that is a
truly prehistoric fish like I don't
think it's changed in millions and
millions of years that's an alligator
yeah yeah these things live
in Texas there here in the state yeah
yeah people fish for them and they get
[ __ ] oh man look that that one right
there is clear that as an head of an
alligator in the body of a fish yeah
it's called a what an alligator gar and
their body is armored like they're those
those scales you have to cut through
them with wire cutters like if you try
to cut through that [ __ ] with like a
regular like a buck knife or something
like that no offense to buck you know
like a Swiss Army knife or some [ __ ]
it's not good enough man look at the
size of that one that guy's holding in
the water look at the [ __ ] size of
the thing
pull up giant alligator gar see if you
because I think that I think they get
into the hundreds of pounds I mean what
are you catching these with what does
bait for this like it's a good question
something big
Jesus Christ but they look at the one of
the operators home in the mouth of it
look at that [ __ ] I saw glimpse of that
pop up out of the water I cut my own
line I'd say [ __ ] that [ __ ] look at
that thing it's such a creepy old
dinosaur I mean at towers over that guy
it's not even close eight feet three
inches long 230 pounds that's soul and
that's a freshwater animal too - 327
Broken Bow Lake Oklahoma - dolphin stuck
together look at that thing and you look
at that yeah that's good you cut through
all that they caught that one in
Nicaragua so I guess they're all over
everywhere but yeah you take them you
got to cut through that scale that scaly
outside with wire cutters and then once
you get through all that you you take
the meat and they really like to smoke
in it put on a smoker that's apparently
the best way this guy's little baby ones
in his fish tank they're a vicious
little creature I mean they actually
stay I mean that's what blows me away as
they start that small
yeah and he's [ __ ] with him right here
yeah we you can I think you can have him
in a fish tank
oh he's feeding him a fish oh yeah
that's a whole fish yeah dinosaurs man
yeah how long about alligator gars been
around find out I think I'm gonna guess
I'm gonna guess thirty million years
they've been that way might be more
thirty million alligators I think it's
been they've been around before the
dinosaurs Strait done yeah they've been
around I think in the same form since
before that meteor hit looking like that
yeah I think so
might be wrong first description is 1803
the first description of them yeah but
like how long have they been in that you
find that out how would you find that
out yeah whatever oldest [ __ ] dinosaur
fishing I mean I'm used to seeing those
people pull out big carp and catfish
yeah I've never I've never seen anything
like that yeah those are big-ass fish
they bow hunt for them - I was gonna ask
you
one picture looked like it had a bow in
it yeah they do
yeah a lot of people do that you go in
those those rivers and they do it at
night to that they'll have like
spotlights so you see the fish in the
water you're shooting something that's
like six feet away from you and they use
like recurve bows that are made designed
just for bow fishing and they have like
a spool on it and you shoot into it and
just and then they just pull it in by
hand or they have a reel that's a how
the hell they pulling that thing forever
300 pounds yeah it takes forever yeah
there's some videos of guys catching
them it's [ __ ] crazy when you watch
them fight these things see if you get a
video of a guy catching an alligator gar
kind of test line you got to have for an
alligator rated braided line they have
that like heavy-duty braided line and
they use a leader like a wire leader
big-ass [ __ ] hooks damn yeah go for
up to 40 grand for a aquarium and a
Japanese black market it says 41 of
those little ones like we just solved
and say the size it just says that the
40 grand in Japan huh yeah 15 note as
high as 40 what would you say black
markets it's probably illegal or so
there's a article if someone getting
arrested for it oh dude that was uh in
Maryland this thing happened III don't
know the full story but it was called
snake heads and I think somebody put
them in the water yeah they're from
Africa and they bred whoa I think that
thing yeah they take over those snake
heads that's a real common thing and
sometimes what they do is they'll poison
everything in the lake to kill the snake
heads and then start from scratch and
then restock the lake so that's
definitely somebody put that in there
yeah yeah definitely I think snake heads
like I said I think they're from Africa
but they're from somewhere else for sure
you know what this guy he's got monster
on there how do you get the hook out of
that mouth I'll be maybe it's just too
tired by the end just gives up look at
that yeah but again they they're good to
eat this apparently they taste delicious
especially when you smoke them it's got
to feel good to fight that thing all day
bring it in and eat it yes that'll feel
good I've caught some pretty good-sized
fish but nothing like that
I caught a Marlin once did you it was
like
seventy pounds not not a giant one you
know but it was like five minutes into
fishing yeah how long it take you to
bring it in about a half hour it's damn
good yeah it wasn't that big in 70
pounds for Marlin not the biggest the
guy that the boat said that he's they've
caught him you know close to a thousand
pounds a thousand your Marlins are giant
I think I think they go a thousand
pounds they're [ __ ] huge like what do
you think what's a world-record Marlin
find that out but apparently like right
off a Malibu Malibu sport fishing it's a
great place to go fishing it's just is
not a lot of people out here that go
I went deep-sea fishing it's a while ago
now off of I think it might been out of
Huntington we rented a boat just like
six of us the world records thirteen
hundred seventy six pounds caught off at
Kona in 1982 whoo that's a big fish damn
20 damn man I mean that's a boat yeah as
a giant fish and they fly through the
air to and you're fighting them that's
pretty yeah that they get up yeah